i'm going to be giving away
10 of the whole entire profits
of my youtube business to potentially
you
tonight so at 7 pm i'm going to be
revealing
the exact amount of money that youtube
have paid me that i've earned from
youtube very much i've been
doing youtube for over five years i got
a total of 16 million
just over 16 million views haven't ran
ads
on a lot of those videos to be fair but
uh how much money have youtube paid me
how much of like in total of the
lifetime of doing youtube
daily videos how much have i made from
youtube
guess in the comment box how much you
think it is
and if you get the exact right amount
okay the first person to guess the exact
right amount i'm gonna give ten percent
or in fact no i'm gonna get fifty
i'm going to give 50 of the total amount
to you just for guessing the exact
right amount so comment below what you
think it is
i'll be uploading the video at 7pm
and i look forward to seeing the results
see you real soon i'll see you at 7